this video is sponsored by the book
summary service
blinkist the first 100 people to use the
link in the description will receive one
free week and 25
off a full membership out of nothing
somehow everything emerged out of this
everything
somehow we emerged back into nothing
inevitably we will along with everything
else
resubmerge sandwich between two slices
of apparent nothingness
what could possibly be this
somethingness that we are aware of
that we are a part of with no clear
origins to call our backstory
and no grand end goal to strive toward
and call our true purpose
we are left individually and
collectively with all roads
seemingly going the way of oblivion if
this is true
what can possibly be derived from
everything other than nothing
all beliefs all convictions all
valuations
swallowed up by the end of everything
ultimately become
nothing of course many might not agree
with the previous statements
but for those who do for those who agree
with them to at least some extent
they are in or are at least approaching
the realm of philosophy
known as nihilism nihilism as a general
way of thinking
can arguably be traced back as early as
the ancient greeks and likely even
earlier
the actual term nihilism however was not
properly conceived and defined until the
19th century
when philosopher friedrich heinrich
jacoby used it to criticize ideas and
theories
associated with the enlightenment era
rationalism and transcendental idealism
particularly jacoby feared that
enlightenment rationality would lead to
a sort of nihilism
as a consequence of it explaining away
religion and
ultimately devaluing the human sense of
self
although jacobi was the first to
properly use the term nihilism wouldn't
really garner any significant cultural
recognition
until it later appeared in the novel
fathers and sons
written by russian author yvonne
turganiev in 1862
in which turgani have used the term in
his characters to express the cynicism
that the younger generation of 19th
century russia felt toward tradition
authority and previously established
intellectual ideals
the term nihilism would soon become
associated with russian revolutionary
activity
and would meld into what is now known as
the russian nihilist movement
unlike what is more commonly accepted as
nihilism today however
the russian nihilism of this time did
not necessarily deny the possibility of
concrete ethics
knowledge or human meaning but rather
focused on destroying and re-evaluating
pre-existing ideals and traditions
in order to create anew the more common
modern concept of nihilism however
goes quite a bit further in general
depending on who you ask
there are four to six different forms of
contemporary nihilism
this includes epistemological political
moral
metaphysical cosmic and existential
what is most commonly referred to when
discussing nihilism however
is existential nihilism existential
nihilism which moving forward here will
simply be referred to as nihilism
as the position that human life has no
intrinsic meaning or value
and all values and meanings that
humanity seeks or creates
are baseless and without merit moreover
it also argues that humanity as a whole
is without purpose or significance to
the universe and the universe is
fundamentally chaotic
meaningless and indifferent to us
the most notable figure associated with
the contemporary form
and development of existential nihilism
as 20th century philosopher
friedrich nietzsche nietzsche was
perhaps the first individual to publicly
and properly assess the incoming wave of
nihilistic thinking
as a general and widespan consequence of
the modern world
noting that with the increasing collapse
of religion and the metaphorical death
of god
man would find himself without any
external basis to derive his ultimate
meaning
and purpose from what i relate is the
history of the next two centuries
i describe what is coming what can no
longer come differently
the advent of nihilism for some time now
our whole european culture has been
moving as toward a catastrophe
nietzsche wrote as time would progress
and the effects of the enlightenment era
became increasingly dominant
nietzsche's predictions would ultimately
come true and nihilism
in at least some form or another would
span the globe like a virus that feeds
on the mind
in the realm of the conceptual
still to this day nihilism seems to have
only continued its endemic course
at least in some manner the more we
learn about existence and the universe
the more we have realized it does not
have much of anything to do with us
the more we dig the farther away we
become the more
nihilism wedges into the base of our
being
with nihilism having and continuing to
be arguably one of the leading
philosophical issues facing the modern
era
there are several notable philosophers
and schools of thought that have made it
one of their chief focuses to resolve
early 19th century philosopher soren
kierkegaard who slightly preceded
nietzsche
was arguably one of the first
kierkegaard argued that although life is
filled with despair
uncertainty and loomed by death there
remains the possibility for true meaning
and purpose
the catch is however it is simply beyond
our rational abilities to comprehend
and so according to kierkegaard we must
take a leap of faith
beyond and despite rationality
specifically
for kierkegaard this meant a leap of
faith into the belief and trust in the
christian god
arguably however this concept of the
leap of faith can also be applied to any
passionate
personal and subjective belief that
extends beyond logic and reason
however the fairly obvious problem here
is that it requires using reason
to arrive at the conclusion to discard
reason essentially by force and the
constraint of no alternative
it is not as if one necessarily is nor
should be satisfied
with their life's meaning being derived
from something that they cannot know nor
comprehend
that is hardly a solution but more of a
surrender
returning to nietzsche who attempted to
tackle the issue within the secular
realm argued that nihilism
isn't exclusively harmful and delineated
it into two forms
passive and active nihilism he argued
that if one holds the position of
passive nihilism
which he defined as the belief that
there will never be any sort of
satisfactory meaning in life
and that all attempts are futile and
illusory then this would be a
self-terminating form
that is negative and destructive to
man's spirit however if nihilism were to
be used or perhaps leveraged
as a way of destroying disagreeable
ideals and beliefs
imposed by collective influences one
could use the newfound negative space
to create anew for themselves and
nihilism here would be more of a means
to an end
rather than an end in it of itself
nietzsche called this active nihilism
and argued that it allowed the
individual to continuously adapt their
life
and form new authentic personal meaning
passive nihilism however is not without
notable philosophical support as well
in many ways it parallels the
philosophical pessimism associated with
arthur schopenhauer and buddhism
whose solutions generally involve a sort
of fatalistic
headlong acceptance of reality
detachment from desire and the pursuit
of earthly endeavors
acting with universal compassion and the
reduction of expectations
in general
[Music]
following and largely inspired by the
path of nietzsche another later response
to nihilism
was taken up by the philosophical
movement known as existentialism
existentialism was most notably formed
and popularized in france in the
mid-20th century
by philosophers jean-paul sartre and
albert camus
agreeing with the premise of nihilism
existentialism essentially argues that
human life
is in fact intrinsically without purpose
or meaning
however it goes on to argue like
nietzsche that through individual
existential freedom and self-awareness
man possesses the ability to create his
own purpose for himself
through his choices and actions thus
rendering a potential meaningfulness to
life
and theoretically resolving the
nihilistic conclusion
life has no meaning a priori it is up to
you to give it a meaning
and value is nothing but the meaning
that you choose sartre wrote
slightly deviating from sartre camus
argued that one should embrace the
absurdity of the human condition as a
means of solution
specifically the relationship between
the human desire for meaning and
resolution
and the universe's cold meaningless
silence
man stands face to face with the
irrational he feels within him his
longing for happiness and for reason
the absurd is born of this confrontation
between the human need
and the unreasonable silence of the
world kemu wrote
kamu would refer to the active embrace
of this absurd relationship
as revolt which essentially translates
into living life without the need or
dependence on consolation
and rather rebelling against the
implications of one's mortality
and existential limitations by living
and trying
and caring anyway despite no real
prospect for future hope
or reason outside the present and
passionate moments of life
i establish my lucidity in the midst of
what negates it
i exalt man before what crushes him and
my freedom
my revolt and my passion come together
then in that tension
that lucidity and that vast repetition
yes man
is his own end and he is his only end if
he aims to be something
it is in this life camus wrote this
position would ultimately form into what
would become known
as the philosophy of absurdism the
problems with existentialism and
absurdism are not necessarily hard to
find
even disregarding the likely faulty
existentialist premise
that man has free will ultimately if one
finds life to be fundamentally
meaningless
and if one desires a greater or absolute
meaning to life
beyond just their personal subjective
imagination which they cannot have
then how can one still find sufficient
meaning can we truly make a sculpture of
the world without any clay to sculpt
with
must we imagine the clay while we sculpt
with nothing
in his book the myth of sisyphus camus
suggested that we imagine sisyphus
the king condemned to the futile work of
eternally rolling a rock up and down a
hill
happy but what if he is not is imagining
enough
arguably at least some portion of us
want more than to imagine
want more than to push a boulder up a
hill we want to be a part of a grand
lucid objective
purpose beyond ourself we want the
boulder to go somewhere
to mean something
[Music]
of course this isn't necessarily the
case for everyone
perhaps for some the leap of faith of
kierkegaard is enough
for others perhaps the act of nihilism
of nietzsche and existentialism
or the revolt in the absurd reasoning of
kamu perhaps for others the sort of
detached asceticism or fatalism of
schopenhauer
and buddhism perhaps for some it's
something else unmentioned
but perhaps still for some the solution
remains to be seen
perhaps there is still room to do better
of course there have been many writers
and thinkers that have followed the
initial era of existentialism and
nihilism
but arguably these initial 19th and 20th
century methods
seem to still remain the primary
foundation and sealing
to our thinking toward nihilism
humankind has defeated and eradicated
diseases by the likes of smallpox and
rinderpest
learned how to open itself up and fix
its organs from the inside
tamed in mitigated elements of nature
like bacteria and extreme weather
built four hundred thousand pound
machines that fly through the sky like
birds
and so so much more but yet we still
have not come anywhere close to
explaining why we are truly here
or how to properly and robustly create a
universal why
fundamentally for anything perhaps then
one of humanity's great oncoming future
achievements will not merely be that of
discovering new realms of the cosmos
and laws of physics or developing new
digital technologies
or curing cancer and other major
diseases but also
forming a new branch of philosophy
science some combination
or whatever else has yet to come that
helps provide an undeniably robust
meaning to life
without compromise without blind faith
without self-imagining
[Music]
at some point in human history the
philosophy of nihilism did not exist
nor existentialism nor absurdism nor any
of the rest
at some point in human history perhaps
another new philosophy
will emerge in true nihilist form we
must admit we are not there yet
and negate and destroy and rebuild until
we are
it might be the case that we have zero
significance in a universe of utter
indifference
or it might be the case that we have
fundamental significance
in a universe destined to evaluate
itself highly and with grand gesture
through us with us and because of us if
we don't know
and perhaps can't know a sort of
agnostic nihilism seems like the most
appropriate response
at least for now and if this is true the
possibility for new unwavering objective
meaning
is at least potentially still on the
table
this video was sponsored by blinkist
over the past decade or so the average
nonfiction bestselling book has been
somewhere between 270 and 480 pages long
let's take the medium at 375 pages
roughly it takes an average reader about
1.7 minutes to read one book page
meaning at 375 pages it takes about 10
hours and 38 minutes
to read one complete non-fiction book in
that same amount of time
the same person could learn from about
42 non-fiction books
using the book summary app blinkist if
that person otherwise read just five
books per year
this would then extrapolate out to
learning from 210 books with blinkist in
the same year
with no additional time blinkist allows
you to do this by condensing thousands
of complete non-fiction books
into convenient 15-minute summaries that
provide their main ideas
overviews and key takeaways of course
you are getting a condensed version of
these books
but with the amount of time saved and
the ability to engage in such larger
quantities
and wider ranges of books and authors
you'll have all the more time and be all
the better equipped to determine the
right books to go on and read fully
and ultimately create an overall more
versatile and effective reading process
and now for the topics and books that
you do want to read fully blinkist also
has full-length audio books that can be
purchased directly within the app
as well as unique consolidated summaries
of popular podcasts
blinkist has 27 categories with
thousands of titles to choose from
and if you're interested in learning
more about philosophy and its history
blinkist has excellent titles like great
thinkers by elaine de viton
beyond good and evil by nietzsche and at
the existentialist cafe
by sarah bakewell as well as many more
and many other subjects
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access
as well as 25 percent off a full
membership the free seven day trial can
be canceled at any time within the trial
period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you